hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neu video schalte
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut ich
freue mich mega weil es ist endlich also
es ist endlich soweit ich glaube das
heutige video wird das coolste video
seid wirklich lange zeit habe ich habe
richtig lust dass jetzt endlich zu
drehen ich habe das im letzten jahr
schon so ein bisschen angeteasert da
ging es um diese apple mystery boxen ob
ich die bestellen sollte und ich muss
sagen ich hatte die am samstag am
samstag haben wir dieses real mystery
box was jan rainer klopfer also dass das
glaube ich bis heute noch nicht
eigentlich sollte an dem tag dieses
apple mystery zeugs kommen ich habe die
sachen schon weitaus vorbestellt auch
mit expressversand da stand zwei bis
drei werktage das ist ja worldwide
shipping weil ich meine die kommen aus
amerika also ich habe extra mehr bezahlt
damit das schneller ankommt war halt
irgendwie nicht so also es hat echt
lange gedauert was dann noch dazu kam
ich habe im internet ich kann euch das
gerne hier mal ein bin einige
bewertungen dafür gefunden dass es so
scam ist und so dass da nur scheiße drin
ist und sonst was alles und ich bin
einfach mal gespannt ob das heute wieder
ein absoluter flop wird oder nicht auf
dieser seite zum beispiel hat die
website mystery box s.com 11 reviews und
nur 1,36 sterne
das ist wirklich unterirdisch
servicewert shipping zurücksetzen
qualität alles nur ein stern das ist ja
nicht wirklich vertrauenserweckend und
bist ja ich hatte ein bisschen angst der
fans ganz nice hat eine 20 $ surprise
mailbox bestellt oder iphone 6 plus
erhalten der hier hat eine 50 dollar
apple box bestellt so wie ich auch und
hier steht drin
der hat nicht mal irgendwelche items
bekommt die irgendwie mit apple in
verbindung stehen stattdessen fünfter
lafitte spinner gut das ist dann
natürlich auch immer ein risiko und ich
glaube dass es bei vielen mystery box
anbietern der fall dass da leute halt
schnell nicht zufrieden sind ja seht
selbst
man muss sagen ich habe 200 dollar über
200 dollar mit dem ct 200h sehe ich
gerade 197
dollar 17 dafür bezahlt was an sich ja
schon eine große summe ist ich meine so
ist halt nur für ein video und hier um
handelt es sich wir haben hier eine
apple mystery boxe ich habe gleich drei
stück bestellt weil ich dachte wenn
schon denn schon wenn ich jetzt hier nur
eine auspacke und da ist halt nix drin
oder irgendein rotz dann ist das auch
langweilig und direkt preis stück es
muss ja geil wäre eine kostet hier 49
999 keine ahnung was das wir soll gegen
diesen countdown ja also
vertrauenswürdig ist was anderes egal
unsere apple misery box wird eine der
folgenden produkte enthalten
random ausgesucht wir haben hier ein
apple iphone iks 256 gigabyte das ding
kostet ja neue sicherlich so um die 700
euro würde ich dann eine apple watch
series vier auch nicht günstig appletv
4k lightning airports nike spot band
keine ahnung was das ist das von apple
dann silicon case für apple iphone shop
to face ach so sonja unterhalt noch ein
iphone charger und vielleicht auch noch
an ich weiß nicht ich bin einfach mal
gespannt des paketes angekommen und ich
habe eigentlich mit etwas ganz anderem
gerechnet also ja es sieht aus wie von
von muss sozusagen das ist das paket ich
da sind halt wahrscheinlich alle drei
mystery boxen drin das ist aber ganz
klar von dieser firma hierauf auch oder
diesem anbieter was auch immer ja dann
wollen wir mal oder
ich bin so gespannt ich hoffe also was
die verpackung angeht haben die sich auf
jeden fall nicht lumpen lassen und
ordentlich dieses ja es hat nicht so
amerikanisches absperrband oder so oder
so viele baustellen reihe egal
das lustige ist ich benutze einfach für
so was immer mein ganz normales so zum
wo ich auch nutella mit auf brot mache
ich brauche eigentlich mal so ein profi
messer oder
jetzt bin ich gespannt leuten ok 123 wir
sind auf jeden fall drei pakete noch mal
einzeln drin ihr könnt ja jetzt super
gerne mal kommentieren was glaubt ihr
wer dich erhalten habe ich am ende diese
200 dollar wieder raus oder nicht ich
tippe mal auf nein weil ich bin halt so
ein bisschen ich habe diese ganze
bewertungen gelesen aber viel mit scam
und sowas weil theoretisch könnten die
einfach irgendwie so eine iphone hülle
hereinlegen jedes und hätten halt den
miesesten gewinnen wird das licht auf
jeden fall in die absolut ja das ist das
erste was oben drin sagt wir haben ja so
eine leiter
das riecht ja wirklich richtig da hat
einer daran gekoppelt wir haben ja so
eine schatzkarte oder sowas
ok mystery box do you like this series
ölpreises und true adventure thank you
for purchase or is you good luck
das ist ja nett dann wünsche ich mir
dass du auch mal und es ist jetzt kam
mit hier alles das riecht wirklich
richtig krass angekokelt wahrscheinlich
sitzt sein amerika einen amateur und
baut diese ganzen pakete dazu sagen hier
gibt es auch noch so anderem mystery
boxen supreme und so ihr könnt ja meine
kommentare schreiben wenn ich da was
bestellen soll
also wenn hier ist schon scheiße drin
ist werde ich dann egal wir machen jetzt
erst mal 123
das sind die drei besten boxen insgesamt
wollen wir jetzt an sich ein wert 150
dollar ca ich bin schon jetzt wirklich
ein bisschen nervös muss ich sagen man
muss sagen da steht was von apple tv
hielt der kann er hier schon mal nicht
drin sein das wäre wahrscheinlich auch
super teuer gewesen für die wenn ihr so
einen fernseher hat bis nach deutschland
schicken müssen ein iphone wird
wahrscheinlich reinpassen airports und
alles andere auch fangen wir hiermit man
mit der linken oder solche mit anfangen
die tu ich erstmal vom tisch
gib mir was geiles ich muss auch mal
glück haben im leben
nix oder pilze
kläger 50 dollar für eine verkappte tik
tok dann gebt mir doch bitte einfach
eine ohne dieses tik tok logo einen tick
tock airports case vor allem ich hab so
viele airports fest dass sie jetzt zwar
wo ich hatte auch schon mal so ein ich
weiß es nicht genau das ist das erste
paket einfach ein airport case ja ich
glaub es auch weiter
ich würde mich ich würde nie wieder nie
wieder in meinem ganzen leben eine
mystery box gestellt
wenn hier jetzt nur so scheiße drin ok 2
habe ich noch 100 dollar mystery box ist
apple mit reebok sind noch übrig was ich
kurz sagen wollte es wird dieses jahr im
dezember wieder so einen kleinen
adventskalender geben ich werde noch
richtig dick einkaufen und wieder ein
paar sachen für euch kaufen die ihr dann
gewinnen könnt auf jeden fall auch
wieder ein handy playstation und so was
alles und alles was wir jetzt in den
musikboxen haben werde ich auch nicht
selber weitere dazu diesen verlosungen
dazu packen es wollte schon mal sagen
deswegen lohnt es sich sehr zu
abonnieren
okay wir haben jetzt noch zwei übrig mit
welcher soll ich anfangen
ene mene miste es rappelt in der kiste
denen mehmet und du bist weg
ok dann nehmen wir die hier gebt mir was
gutes bitte einfach irgendwas geiles
eine apple bosch brauche ich noch also
gut ich muss sagen wenn hier eine apple
watch drin ist das wäre das einzige was
ich selber behalten würde
weil ich mir immer mal einen zulegen
wollte und halt noch keine habt den rest
davon brauche ich brauche ich nicht das
würde ich halt alles dann zu der
verlosung dazu packen bitte eine handy
würde also silicon case
ich habe schon gesehen das ist so ein
ding kostet halt wirklich nur 50 cent
wenn überhaupt in der produktion
wahrscheinlich zwei cent und das tut er
da rein
ich habe drei boxen bestellt und ich
kriege bis jetzt ein silikon airport
case mit tik tok logo drauf und diese
scheiße ich habe es geahnt leute ohne
scheiß ich habe es geahnt dass es
absolut flott und wieder kacke ist
genauso wie dieses real video das könnt
ihr euch gerne anschauen das war also
das ist das glaube ich bis heute noch
nicht ich habe aber auch noch nicht die
beschwerde melder verpasst das muss ich
eigentlich auch noch machen
jetzt haben wir hier alle hoffnungen in
die letzte box warte mal kurz ich habe
eine idee ich kenne mal kurz das gewicht
das gewicht hier vergleichen es ist auch
nicht auch nicht wirklich schwer aber
ich glaube es ist ein bisschen schwerer
als das ein ganz kleines bisschen
schwerer schon okay also
es ist deutlich schwerer ich merke dass
ich glaube es ist es könnte vielleicht
sogar ein handy so drin sein wobei da
ist es vielleicht ein bisschen zu leicht
höheren okay gibt es aber kaum hatte er
das
es ist ein handy oder das könnte
wirklich einhält oder an der treppe ich
glaube das ist meine apple what was kann
es noch sein mike dass das sport band
das ist zu zu leicht und alles andere
für airports könnten seien heute ich
mache mit augen zu ich mache einfach mit
augen zurück
1 weg von hier weg ach so das waren
schon beide froh ich habe es sind glaube
ich glaub ich erwarte heute ich hab
immer noch augen zu und ja es müssen
airport sein vielleicht sind es pro das
wäre absolut nice bei die habe ich nicht
denkt ihr seht ja schon ich nicht ich
mache jetzt meine augen auf 321 ja geil
der putz ist schon ist schon nice ich
bin ein bisschen erleichtert weil ich
dachte es flott wieder erweist und
airports airports für die erst zweite
generation denke ich mal hergestellt
sechster 2020 ja wir haben airports der
zweiten generation leider keine airports
pro aber die werden ja auch so was
kosten die die kosten schon sich wenig
oder
also man muss sagen in amerika sind die
immer noch ein bisschen günstiger hier
kosten jetzt 164 euro auf amazon dann
haben wir noch gut die cases zähle ich
einfach mal nicht dazu das kostet nichts
ich muss das jetzt ein neuer kurs
ausrechnen leute weil das mir voll
wichtig ihr könnt super gerne daumen
nach oben da lassen bei 6.000 likes
bestelle ich nochmal vier weitere boxen
dort und vielleicht ziehen wir dann ja
ein handy oder so dass wir halt geist
kann oder ihr könnt mir auch super gerne
irgendwelche boxes schicken die ich
irgendwo bestellen kann einfach
fensterrahmen oder so da werde ich die
auch bestellen wenn der hsv ist was mich
anspricht das hat mich 198 dollar
gekostet mal umrechnungskursen 0,8 568
euro die kosten 164 euro
ja wahrscheinlich haben wir die für ein
bisschen also ich sage mal so die sind
absolut mit null raus gegangen und ich
bin an sich mit vier euro verlust
ausgegangen ich denke was haye wenn man
da nur eine box bestellt das zu 100%
einfach nur seine sondern iphone case
drin ist oder irgendwo muss ja bei so
was auch der harten sein und diese
ganzen negativen rezensionen im internet
wie gesagt habe ich euch wahrscheinlich
ein eigentor allem an die jüngeren von
euch ich würde absolut davon abraten da
jetzt irgendwie geld auszugeben für so
ein quatsch
lasst es besser lass das lieber meine
aufgabe
ansonsten habe ich jetzt hier die
airport city kommen auf jeden fall schon
mal zu der dezember verlosung dazu das
war's ich schwitze ein bisschen ich
würde mich sehr freuen wenn ihr mal bei
meinem anderen kanal vorbei schaut da
gibt es jetzt ab und zu mal oder
eigentlich jeden tag fifa videos und
bisschen anders weil ich das immer
nebenbei spiele war denke ich euch oben
in der beschreibung würde mich sehr
freuen
das was von mir ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen lassen nach oben und ja haut
rein